[Music]
it's time for et's social study your
quick look at what the stars are posting
online JLo's got a sleek new haircut
Jennifer Lopez chopped her long tresses
into an edgy middling due on Monday she
gave you the new look at the NBC summer
press day where she revealed she limped
off one piece of pizza a day as a dancer
I'm still jenny from the block meanwhile
Zayn Malik tease a new collaboration
with rapper partynextdoor Zane promised
fans on Twitter the single still got
time is coming soon I mean Kendra
Wilkinson took to Instagram to celebrate
meeting husband Hank Baskett nearly a
decade ago with this heartfelt message
nine years ago I met the person who
would take me all the way to the top and
hold me there even during the weakest
times while Celine Dion shared this rare
family photo in celebration of her mom's
90th birthday and looks like Reese
Witherspoon little boy Tennessee is
having a tough time spelling his name we
shared this photo with the hashtag
preschool problems
you